today's topic mark williams is a 36 year
old corrections officer from rancho
cucamonga california this is not gonna
end well correction officer
you are losing your job sir he has been
married to his second wife for nine
years and has a daughter and a son he
was asked over 50 questions by our
polygraph examiner 21 of those questions
have been chosen for tonight mark
williams this is your moment of truth
so gonna be able to tell the truth in
front of all of america tonight i will
tonight i will tell the truth for all
america to see
also telling it in front of your family
and friends let's see who's come here to
hear you tell the truth
hi my name is nora and i'm mark's wife
hello my name is brandon i'm mark's
friend for 18 years hi my name is celine
and i've also known mark for 18 years my
name is reggie rogers and i'm mark's
hi i'm pauline moore and i've known mark
since high school hi my name is reggie
i've known mark for about 18 years i
mean they look like a motown group yeah
yeah the marks
because it kind of looked like him too
shoot
okay remember if you're ever concerned
about the answers you gave on your
polygraph exam you can change them
tonight just let me know
okay
i understand you work corrections
officers right i'm a correctional peace
officer
this man fast this man's faces are weird
yes
do you think the law is the same for
everybody yeah pretty action absolutely
yeah that's the same okay absolutely
i believe in our justice system
yo
damn i believe in it
i'm still keeping my job right right
this is not gonna go well
have you ever used your job as a
corrections officer
to avoid being cited for a traffic
violation
you see how they fit on that
he's not instead of that look at
his face he turned chatty
you see how they set up that
[Music]
yes
a corrections officer telling you that
the law is equal is like a billionaire
telling you the tax code works for
everybody equally
okay
that answer is
true
what is this
so you believe you have open
communication with your wife nora
absolutely is that true nora he tries
very hard
question two did you ever tell your wife
you had to work late when in fact
you were doing something else
[Music]
look at his face
why is he side-eyeing her
yes
that answer is
[Music]
true
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a nervousness i don't think it's
nervous some people are just expressive
with their face he's nervous
you've been married you said uh nine or
so years yeah ten years going on going
on ten years
would you say that you and norah have
each other's back
i think so yeah a question could be like
sir when noah's not looking do you ever
think of just grabbing a knife and
stabbing her in the back
he's gonna be a question like that yeah
[Laughter]
you know sometimes nurses gets on my
nerves i'm like ah listen i hang around
murderers all day so what if i just
murder her i'm already in the facility
let me just be a prisoner and you know
the law
yeah yeah
question three
[Music]
have you ever lied to nora about how her
butt looks in a pair of pants
[Music]
yes
that answer is
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not gonna go home
he's not nervous
this thing is just weird
[Music]
okay no that's the editing that's the
editing this girl didn't just go from
like getting up and showing her ass
she'd be like
did they edit this she did god i was
like yeah my ass looked good sat down
it's true okay
so you do lie to me okay mark
what makes you feel good you know
shopping driving uh listening to music
um
shopping for my wife uh nice clothes
nice clothes you know i love yeah you
know you're sharp dresser well why thank
you thank you you're welcome
question five
have you ever worn women's underwear
these
play that back
wait no no play that back now knowing
that that's the outcome
i want to see it now that i know that
that's the outcome mark
what makes you feel good
we gotta talk the way you set up these
questions you and the producers was just
evil
have you ever worn women's underwear
[Applause]
listen the fact that you even have to
think about it you're guilty
do you
exactly see this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes
that's how they got up they got up like
yeah they could fight the white power
[Applause]
true
okay
[Applause]
okay yes mark now let me tell you what
happened tell me what happened because i
know that the prisoners in the
correctional place are going to want to
know all about that
margin
is up mark is on his toes i
appreciate mark yeah
okay here's the situation you know how
sometimes you don't have you know maybe
your underwear is not clean right
this particular day i was out of
underwear
and i tried on a pair of noise shirts
just to get me through for a couple of
hours for shorts
yeah until they got through i didn't
have any clean underwear so i didn't
have anything so i put i put them on
sweet
has brandon ever tried on your underwear
shorts
yes
this
this turned into a whole mess
your boy's not even on the panel he's
not making any money and you earn this
thing ahead
you're throwing it under the bus and
here's what i think is funny this is
probably not even true but the wife
couldn't wait yes he has that's what you
get for sleeping with that
i got you on tv yeah you gonna be
at work like daddy they gonna call you
sweet pants
[Music]
[Laughter]
see see
ya
[Laughter]
yeah
he is a motown
look it is
you dropped a bomb on
do me wear women's underwear yes you
jumped
on me
baby
question nine
have you ever asked someone to follow
your ex-wife without her knowledge
[Applause]
[Music]
why do you even have to think about that
no nobody thinks like that hey you
ever suck dick
[Music]
yes i have
that answer
[Music]
[Applause]
intentional true mark you're doing great
you need two more to get to 25 do you
like to travel
yeah i like to travel
we've traveled a few times as a question
you'll be like have you ever tried
travel to cheat on your wife how far
have you gone to another woman
question 11 for 25 000
have you ever done anything in las vegas
you don't want your wife to know about
you you think the divorce yeah i think
this dead
[Music]
yes
that answer is
true
[Applause]
25 000 is yours i'm happy that you've
done that that's 11 truthful answers
that's more than halfway to 500 000
question 12
have you done anything illegal
in the last six weeks
so
no
i have not
that answer is
we're all good we're all good
this is the first time he hasn't made a
bunch of weird faces so now i'm super
nervous no no not that you have to
reinsure it yeah yeah no we're all good
we are good guys guys guys we're good
[Applause]
you going to jail now
this question scared me mark
not that i thought you committed any big
crime but this scared me unfortunately
mark when asked this question on your
polygraph
polygraph determined that you were being
deceptive
why do you think it came up as a false
have you done anything illegal in the
last six weeks
maybe it's speeding i have no i'm i'm
totally blown away mark i'm so sorry
there's no money for you today wow
really sorry about that
really sorry my friend
so no money for mark
do you know what i have to say about
this
no no that man was a clown
man was a clown
you know put a clown emoji in the chat
for this man oh my days
put a clown emoji everybody that has
seen this if you reach the video after
this put a cloud in the middle
clutter clown emoji in the
comments
for this guy one time and then put in a
rfp form because this is
definitely dead
you know fleece johnson's in prison
watching that episode be like
i want you and i'm gonna have you
welcome back john
we could do this that underwear way
or no underwear i know what you did
that's illegal john
so i'm gonna have that booty
[Laughter]
you can't use your handcuffs on me john
anyway someone just stopped i'm gonna
stop there were you any thoughts
no that show is mind-boggling yeah it's
mind-blowing great show but anyways let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below you guys want us to
interview mark wahlberg i want to ask
him a bunch of questions this is crazy
yeah get with him anyways let us know
what you guys think of the comments i
want to hear from you
jesus christ